foreign
in San Antonio hey Jacqueline how are
you
hi guys I'm well thank you better than
we deserve good how can we help you
didn't even match but I answered anyway
what's up you know
I'm on autopilot Jacqueline how can we
help
I have a beautiful responsible 19 year
old daughter who lives with us
um and is about to make me a grandmother
I know it's funny I said responsible
first right
except for that one time yeah yeah okay
yeah my my quest well financially
responsible hard-working excellent work
ethic and and morally sound
um
my question is how much should I be
helping her throughout this pregnancy
and throughout the first month
um it was obviously unplanned
um and she's had a hard time with
processing the the whole thing and she
is now unable to work so
I'm I'm just kind of
looking to you um it was sort of a light
came on as I was driving and listening
to you and I thought I respect Dave's
answers so let's run it by him
well I appreciate that
um
sometimes when I'm facing something like
that that is um
a little bit ethically or morally or I
don't even know those those aren't the
right words uh relationally
overwhelming
um it helps me to say
not what is the right answer today but
what do I do today that is the right
answer for 10 years from now
exactly because we we have a strong
foundation with our kids of teaching
them financial responsibility you know
we go by yours for years and years and
so what what you've got is creating
circumstances obviously obviously a baby
is an awesome wonderful thing
particularly grandbabies if I don't know
how great grandbabies were going to be
I'd have been nicer to their parents
um so you know all of that part is
wonderful so this is a bad metaphor but
I would almost say what if she had a car
wreck and couldn't work
she she ran a red light it was her fault
and then she got hurt right that's not a
really good metaphor because it's not as
babies are much sweeter than that right
but um but I mean that's kind of how I
think I probably would look at it I'm
just thinking like a grandpa right now
or like a dad
and that's where my brain is stuck this
is not a 39 year old who's done heroin
for 15 years and hates me
this is a 19 year old that messed up
made a mistake that otherwise has led a
led a pretty good life is what you're
describing to me
that's correct yeah when our kids
graduate high school thank God God
didn't throw all of us out in the ditch
the first time we made a mistake
so I got lots of grace and mercy in this
situation if it's me I'm just going to
take care of her like she's 17.
yeah and then but but all with the idea
that we're going to lead towards
a sustainable answer when she's 25.
so what's sustainable for her when she's
25 well obviously financial
responsibility career responsibility
mommy responsibility living on her own
and sustaining and developing a life
whether she does that as a single mom or
later on gets married to someone right
you mind if I add one more thing in okay
um when they graduate high school we
have them pay us rent immediately and
the thing is their grades stay up in
college when they graduate they get all
that money back so it's basically
savings if they don't we keep it yeah um
she was able to in school pay us rent
500 a month and she also saved six
thousand dollars working full-time in
six months so she has seven thousand
dollars
in her savings account and really my
question was do I even let her touch
that no are you guys are you guys okay
financially you and your husband
we are we're debt-free besides our house
this is not a financial lesson
this is I'm loving my daughter through a
very very tough time
she had a car wreck
you know and then that's very
very yeah that's what I would do and and
I'm pretty hardcore on tough love as
they call it uh but this is not tough
love this is not a time for that for me
for me this is a little scared pregnant
girl and I'm gonna put my arms around
her I'm a lover She's mine and we're
gonna get her through this but all not
with the idea that she lives in your
basement until she's 39 but the idea
that she's gonna because you gave her
some room here to heal and to not not
heal but to go through this process well
and heal it's been traumatic I'm sure
yes and so um to go through and get back
on her feet emotionally relationally
make better choices going forward this
is not a pattern that represents her
life
um and so let's get back on that track
that that she was on and and then you
got a 25 year old that's a that's an
amazing human being with it's an amazing
mom and and everybody's happy and proud
again I'm not enabling into the distant
future but on the short term here
I just completely take care of her as if
she was in ICU or something what do you
think Georgia yeah I'm with that and I'm
also wondering you said she's unable to
work is that just a short-term thing
what does that look like
it is she um developed a pregnancy
disease around five to six weeks
um in her pregnancy before she could
even process and she became so sick that
she was hospitalized
um the good news is that it does go away
the moment she delivers and she's
managed now the hospitalization helps
them to manage her sickness and so she
is medicated and she's managed at this
point and able to function but it's very
unpredictable so she's not able to get
another job yeah okay this is a 19 year
old
and a baby
take care just take care of them
yeah that's what I would do
uh and that's exactly what I'm going to
do okay you're a good mom you got a good
heart and you're not you know you you've
raised a I know you're tough because you
raised a kid that has work ethic you
raised a kid that's make you're making
her pay rent you raise the kid that did
this and that and this and that and you
know so you're not a pushover enabler
Mom I don't think I didn't hear that
well I think that's where it goes into
the long-term ramifications if this is
still a decade from now and we're still
living like this in the basement that's
where we need to go we need to have an
exit strategy out of this too once she's
healed up and on her feet in my mind
this is the perpendicular opposite of uh
someone who's 31 years old and does this
and is belligerent and says if you don't
help me you'll never see your grandkid
and all that kind of stuff I have a
completely different reaction to that
person than I do this 19 year old kid
and if you're 19 and you don't like me
calling you a kid I got socks older than
you so just calm down that's the deal I
love that just means I love Jews all
that means it doesn't mean that I'm
putting you down but I got a little more
rings around the tree so it's a nice way
a little more age going here so uh you
know that that's the thing so you know
what you're looking for in relational
things period but certainly in um
uh Financial relational things is you're
looking for patterns not singular events
and patterns cause you to endorse a
situation or to avoid a situation and
and that keeps you from becoming an
enabler if you're wondering out there
and you're a mom and a dad so if you've
got a 37 year old that lives in your
basement and will not work that's a
pattern
you need to kick said butt into the
street
because you're not a blessing to them
you are a curse to them you are an
enabler you have stolen their dignity
the Dignity of autonomy the Dignity of
standing on your own the Dignity of hard
work the Dignity of killing something
and dragging at home the only thing they
know how to do is play Nintendo and it's
your fault you should be ashamed that's
a different pattern yeah for moms and
dads and we got that out there because
we got a group of males that aren't yet
men that are stuck in their mommy's
basement and mommy's still doing their
dad gum laundry and if you don't like
that that's okay get you a show this is
mine
so that's how this works